comme chaque année les artistes
demandent aux stylistes de préparer des
tenues de ouf pour être au top
et si certaines sont légèrement sexy
d'autres sont beaucoup trop sexy est-ce
que les nrj music awards c'était mieux
avant oui ici non ici ou tourner en
regarder les tenues rouges héros sortira
le bon moment
dans quelques jours ils vont vivre ce
soir
vous n'arrêtez pas je disais tout à
l'heure vous avez changé trois longues
semaines
dès que du guide ont ce côté un peu plus
maintenant se présente lui votre public
à la c'est super que vous soyez à cannes
sur la croisette et qui ont fait
l'ouverture en sans plomb
je trouve ça d'une vulgarité marier sans
limite
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai quoi les nrj music awards si
lacombe 20e saison
s'il vous plaît merci on me dira alors
comme chaque année dont jours il ya des
looks de ouf
et c'était aussi ce qui est super dans
les nrj music awards c'est que les
gagnants ne sont jamais là les meilleurs
gagnent ça change un peu une haïtienne a
encore à l'année d'après cnet pourquoi
et l'année d'après cm puis voilà puis
enfin c'est un ancien des lignes capcir
xxi matt pokora qui gagnent toujours
et ça moi c'est mon kiff voilà moi c'est
con mais m kenji ou m pokora si
longtemps voilà c'est tout pourri cloué
au lit
ah oui voilà j'aime bien voilà donc
cette année il y habite a aussi des
villages et qui fait alors on a encore
d'énormes surprises
regardez c'est le septième prix qui fait
quand on cette catégorie
ça va faire je crois treize fois qu'il a
été récompensé aux nrj music awards et
le vainqueur et promet des big flo et
oli et le world est attribuée attribué à
vicques ju ow les barreaux
des consécutive merci infiniment pour
l'artiste masculin international de
l'année
j'adore les nrj music awards j'en ai
déjà plusieurs chez moi ça en fera un de
plus nrj music awards c'était mieux
avant ou pas non pour vous raymond c'est
toujours aussi bas a annoncé toujours
c'est moi j'aimais pas avant j'ai choisi
pour y avancer pour une maintenance et
le bahreïn c'est des trucs entre eux ils
restent entre eux on trouve être ses
jumeaux jadwa il reste entre programmes
d'énergie donc je crois en levant une
cérémonie où il ya des loups ils vont
venir chanter mais c'est des gens qui
restent entre eux pour moi c'est le même
endroit ces mêmes décors c'est toujours
matt pokora qui gagne c'est toujours la
low cost aliagas qui apparaît jamais les
chanteurs bas c'est qui c'est quoi c'est
ce qu'ils vendent des disques c'est ce
qui est fait entre eux mais c'est quoi
le truc les énergies au programme qu'en
fait pas moi je moi j'aimerais bien que
tu récompense celui qui a vendu des
disques ils vont avec des gants ils vont
des dix touches on y vend des disques
jana s'ils vont des listes propres
un droit un truc entre nous c'est
l'actualité des artistes énergie
vraiment qu'on écoute sur enel vont
vraiment je trouve que là où l'un des
artistes du moment
alors moi je ne vais pas ranger fait le
tour du public en plus moi j'aimais pas
aux normes toujours pas maintenant sauf
qu'avant il y avait quand même plus
d'étrangers qui ont leur place est me
semble-t-il que l'arbre est ce que là
pour le coup ça faisait vraiment haweij
n'est pas là mais il enregistre un petit
message en fait mais complètement nue
alors alors cette année il ya une haine
qui a cartonné
c'est angel a remporté 2 nm à celui
d'artiste féminine francophone de
l'année et celui de la chanson
francophone de l'année
on a remarqué un truc entre sakho et son
fauteuil à son discours après son prix
voilà on jeunesse est un petit peu lâché
on a kiffé regarder
[Musique]
bah je t'envoie
peut-être changera borges temps quoi
[Musique]
les meufs sommes en train de nous
quelqu'un mais ça fait trop plaisir
votre main si vous
[Applaudissements]
tél
alors les nrj music awards est ce que
c'était mieux avant valérie bénaïm oui
alors moi j'aime les nrj music awards
mais je regardais que c'était beaucoup
mieux avant parce que effectivement
comme l'a dit isabelle il y avait des
artistes amis américains anglais qui se
déplaçait là c'est plus le cas moi j'ai
noté on avait quand même dans les
éditions précédentes il y avait du
madonna du britney spears beyoncé you to
rihanna black eyed peas one direction
sont enregistrés dans le noyau ça fait
deux ans qu'elle en hologramme les âges
étaient présents là sur la dernière sur
cette édition là il y avait les jonas
brothers
voilà alors il y en a un qui a eu une
petite terrasse pendant la soirée
ces nigauds alors pour lui c'était la
soirée de la radem vraiment soirée
d'arras rassuré de la lose on aurait dit
la vie amoureuse de benjamin cassel
regarder le groupe
il a eu que des galets à regarder et
pour commencer la seule fille qui a
gagné deux boys en france avec une
magnifique voix que mel c poussé par la
joueuse est compatible ou les tonnerres
d'applaudissements
[Applaudissements]
voilà réponse
l'artiste irlandais de tous les records
leur duo all ways et la ballade de
l'année philippe il est guéri n'djeng
qui sourire bien tout le monde trouvait
ça peu votre tête en toute amitié juste
hâte hâte parce que j'étais peut-être
aussi merci je vous aime bien mais
attention
alors il faut savoir que kevin james
c'est 50 disques de platine dans le
monde
[Applaudissements]
c'est la boulette de la soirée il croit
que c'est un gars tu peux baisser un
taux là on veut prendre des photos avec
des roses stars james une telle maturité
en dix ans pas de souci non pas de
problème des états il est très sympa
c'est une humiliation on va pouvoir voir
qu'à regarder la boulette de nikos voilà
regarder on voit on va voir cette boule
et non attention petit sourire n'a tout
le monde souhaitait simplement fait en
toute amitié juste hâte parce que je
veux être ici
voilà merci je vous aime bien mais
attention et oui ce n'est pas situé au
clasico
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
le postulat de nikos dans l'oreillette
parce que du coup derrière exactement
alors forcément ils sont en direct donc
forcément sur les réseaux sociaux cette
politique de l'ampleur et avant même la
fin de l'émission de nikos a tenu à
s'excuser auprès de kevin james
regardez juste fait excuser tout à
l'heure parce que aller le médecin au
funk à janet meeks plein et où les
épaules pub et tout à l'heure je suis
venu faire une photographie mais c'était
pour les artistes qui se produisent dans
la performance pour laquelle les
téléspectateurs pour voter c'est vous
n'étiez pas dans cette nomination de
vous et quand j'écoute mon côté je
voulais juste photographié cette
catégorie pour me faire pardonner
permettez moi de faire une série avec
votre téléphone
tout de suite c'est un honneur alors il
faut savoir que ces copeaux je le vois
car ils ont tous d'accord pour dire est
un mensonge
non excuse moi donc on n'avoue pas pour
dire à un autre mensonge
william ça bouge si c'est pour dire ça
c'est nul je veux te dire excusez moi je
faisais pas reconnu dans le stress
oui mais appartenant ou tout le set où
la vue moi je pense que c'est bien dire
la vérité et puis à un moment de mes pas
nikos fin je veux dire même quand bien
même tu l'a pas reconnu ne dis pas ça au
cas où que ce soit une personne que tu
es censé connaître parce que avait après
tout ces années de métier tu fais une
erreur comme ça c'est pierre nguyen
balaiera alors là tu fais pas les
rajustements rayhana qu'à moi on va
revenir dessus
samedi c'était les grandes retrouvailles
vous rappelez vous l'année dernière
nikos avait mal prononcé le nom diana
qu'à moi il s'est trompé sur son nom
rappelé troisième titre 3e artistes en
compétition dans la catégorie chanson
francophone de l'année
jha porte le numéro 3 ce soir vous ne
chantez à la maison voici diaka nakamura
[Applaudissements]
la can à kamouraska est donc cette année
il a tout fait pour ne pas se tromper et
nikos qui ce qu'il a fait il s'est dit
cette année je vais répéter il a répété
avant l'hiver rien nakamura ya nakamura
yana comme moi et là il a fait que de
dire son nom tout est mis sur la déco
son nom parce que d'un peu plus
maintenant se pose en plus votre public
à la tournière d'applaudissements au
port allez à la camorra
pour vous qui d'ailleurs nakamura c'est
le numéro 3 champoux qui a triomphé
[Applaudissements]
asada sort c'est vrai que c'est une
énorme soirée tu peux être privé de sa
compagne alexandra l'oreillette en même
temps alors justement là il ya eu une
petite polémique samedi soir parce que
c'est vrai que sur twitter voilà il ya
plein de gens qui disent il faut
remplacer nikos pour remplacer nico soit
remplacé des mois je personnellement ni
coach de cliff voilà et en plus c'est
comme ça qu'on les aime on aime bien moi
j'aime bien ces boulettes et tous ses
salades harkat et c'est vrai qu'à cauet
qui a assumé sur twitter vous le
remplacez nikos à la présentation des
nma il a répondu à un article du site
pure break qui évoqué le fait qu'ils
pourraient remplacer nikos
j'ai vu tellement de tous les gentils
messages sur mon passage aux nma hier
sur tf1 c'était court mais bon
pure break chiche dont qui serait voilà
plutôt chaud cauet pour remplacer nikos
aux nrj music awards sont sans doute est
un qui serait chaud ils savent ce que
c'est de se heurter à une vieille guerre
entre énergie et f1 moi je les fais une
fois les nrj music awards que l'énergie
voudrait placer ses animateurs et leurs
maisons et tf1 évidemment impose ce lieu
de tf1 mais moi j'ai fait une fois
nettement nikos il fait ce qu'il peut
mais c'est une telle taxe vous pas sa
part pas le magnéto n'est pas prêt le
mec en scène c'est un bon jour c'est une
fait ça tous les soirs fraude et a
renchéri de ces mots c'est mon frère si
il a pas de 43 me jérôme du succès des
débats avec quoi qu'il arrive il faut
gérer les égos de chacun c'est pour lui
c'est vraiment une thalasso nettement il
fait ce qu'il peut mais doc rivers et le
tone yale nicotine est pas le taulier du
tout qui fait comme il peut c'est une
espèce darren ce qu'il a fait les trois
artistes internationaux mois
devrait prendre quelques jours j'ai bien
passé ouvrez moi mais moi franchement
moi je pense que nico s'il fait ça très
bien quand nikos a pu le faire on va
regretter mais là j'en suis sûr vous
pensez qu'il serait bien camille je
pense franchement que de gauche nikos
est la bonne personne pour les lèvres
lakamy je pense qu'il étrenne un homme à
singer normal mais je pense que nikos
est la bonne personne ce que je pense
qu'il faut il faut savoir être un peu il
faut un peu plus d'épaisseur
voilà c'est à dire que voilà je pense
voilà même voilà de chabannes je pense
que j'adore il serait pas bon dans les
neymar c'est le taulier tf1 mine de rien
il faut quand même le taux d un truc
quoi à l'a8 franchement et je dis ça je
dis ça franchement j'aurais peut-être me
arthur boylan huit civils affluent donc
voilà je ramenais une petite pointe
d'humour et qui est quand même un gros
souliers mais quoi exactement voilà faut
savoir que toutes les stars
internationales sont invités aux nrj
music awards une source de souci c'est
qu'elle sont invités mais viennent pas
alors ils sont annoncés mais ils sont
pas là on vous accompagner ces moments
où vous allez même découvrir en exclu
pourquoi a rien à glander n'était pas la
regarder et les gagnants sont lady gaga
et bradley cooper
[Applaudissements]
entre kaka je souhaite tellement rust
avoir importé les prix les méias coûte
seniors les tâches mendes camilla
capello ils n'ont pas pu être là ce soir
désolé les amis
cette baisse ne mobilisait pas avec nous
elle attend du besoin d'un petit peu je
voulais vous remercier infiniment et d
un commercial énergie ayhan a donné le
goût sera envoyé en salle france
je ne peux pas venir nrj music award
pour une raison très simple
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] conduit m'emballer
[Applaudissements]
on l'a on n'a idée rien à aulas rien
dans la vie mais c'est vrai qu'aucune
star n'est venu voilà à part il y avait
quand même les deux à trois heures les
affiches très cher et normalement c'est
les maisons de disques qui prennent ça
en charge et aujourd'hui des maisons
disent ne veulent plus payer pour le
déplacement des ménages font elles pas
elles viennent pas tout seul en général
aliens avec 650 alors les nrj music
awards c'était mieux avant géraldine
maillet nous dit que c'était sans doute
mis en avant par rapport aux stars
internationales mais moi j'ai surtout
détestez-vous qui fait un peu de télé la
réalisation de l'émission alors s'était
trouvé qu'un dessin potes eh ben j'ai
pas du tout aimé
alors il ya d'abord les écrans derrière
les poursuites les spots fait c'est
complètement épileptique ça donne la
migraine ont su bien passé peut-être
voir y'a pas d'émotions vont ensuite
rincée aurifère c'est peut-être ça aussi
on le vit un petit peu de des
spectateurs mais ça a très bien marché
un nrj music awards a mieux marché que
l'année dernière dont c'est vrai qu'on
avait su donner mais france 2 encore
avait eu la bonne idée de ne rien mais
brune face bravo car le téléspectateur
donc voilà c'est vrai ils sont numéro 1
derrière il y avait commissaire magellan
sur france 3 styles roadie fou c'était
du frais dans cette une frêle mais c'est
vrai c'est pas la plus forte série télé
même audience que l'année dernière 2,4
voilà merci yahvé instant il y avait en
france servi 843 téléspectateurs là j'ai
kiffé alors les chéris il ya deux il ya
deux choses que je voudrais revoir c'est
diana qu'à moi elle a fait son live sur
ce coup qui à la fin la fin de tweets
works qui a fait énormément parler voilà
moi je kiffe ce propos j'ai un truc à
kaya nakamura je la kiffe parce que
c'est une rebelle
voilà l'été vénère ne pas gagner ce jeu
qui file en acadie vie je l adore
regarder en moins
prot
[Musique]
gerry byrne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors réagi hal a réagi avec humour sur
twitter répondant à un internaute qui
imaginaient l'état de ses nerfs après le
show puisqu'elle n'a remporté alors
remporté aucun nma cette année et ejelat
qui est bon on l'a pas eu
le tweet voilà on ne l'a pas mais on
leur a donné il était sympa vraiment il
ya une autre sphère un autre que je
voudrais revoir c'est moi mon artiste
préféré
dans la dernière bien sûr il ya big flo
et oli qui ont gagné leurs discours
était génial ils sont formidables et 200
mieux et il ya kara luciani au cas pas
cas j'étais dégoûté parce que c'est
voilà c'était mon titre préféré
l'an dernier alors j'étais dans mon
salon va le mettre
on va le mettre à jour a gagné j'étais
content big flo aider à gagner
il y avait là
dieu n'a rien gagné regarder ce après ça
[Musique]
tant pis 2
j mort comme chaque mois
[Musique]
un gars
sous ce
cela
à coca
son seul
on a
[Musique]
c'est
est-ce que c'était bien avant vous vous
dites non vous vous dites oui on va voir
tout de suite allé qu'est ce que vous
dites le sondage est la wii les losers